I'm Angry…
with all of YOU!
Because you didn't go see
a lot of the best movies of the year!
But you can play catch-up
thanks to my list of the
Top 10 Most Underrated Movies of 2014
on this week's episode of Angry Nerd!
Okay, everyone agrees that television is in
the middle
of a golden age, or platinum age,
...or dilithium age...
...or whatever.
There all these terrific, compelling, challenging
series
from HBO, AMC, Showtime, Netflix, Amazon...
But feature-length movies that play in theaters
are actually still pretty good,
IF you know where to look.
Which, come to think of it,
will probably be your TV screen at this point.
Oh well, here are ten overlooked films
that truly deserve your attention.
Jim Jarmusch's flick
was the most compelling depiction of vampires
I've seen in years.
I mean c’mon, If Dracula was real,
he wouldn't be
a blockbuster action hero
laying waste to rival armies,
or a sparkly teen heart throb
canoodling with
a twitchy wooden actress.
He would waste his days lounging around
and sucking on gourmet bloodsicles
like the decadent Eurotrash that he is.
This half-live action, half-animated
adaptation of Stanislaw Lem's classic sci-fi
satire
is the easily the most mind bending film of
the year.
Robin Wright is terrific
as an actress who sells her likeness rights
to Hollywood
and then crosses over
into a strange, hallucinogenic alternate universe.
It's like Ralph Bakshi's Cool World..
if Ralph Bakshi's Cool World
was NOT absolutely terrible!
Now, you'd hardly know it
from the ad campaign,
but this clever no-budget dramedy
about two couples and their...UNUSUAL relationship
issues
has a HUGE sci-fi twist.
Saying more would spoil it.
Just, just be sure to seek it out.
What a relief to see an action movie
with almost no plot
or dialogue
or special effects
to distract from the action.
BONUS: Google around to find a video
of director Gareth Evans discussing his
top five favorite fight scenes of all time.
His list is one of my Top Five...
Top...
Five lists!
Stephen Chow is like a cross between
Jackie Chan and Peter Jackson:
a master of slapstick comedy, martial arts,
AND digital effects.
He's been all-but-ignored stateside since
Kung Fu Hustle,
but this adaptation of a classic 16th-century
Chinese novel
is worth tracking down.
The greatest sci fi flick of the 1970s was…
...never actually…
...filmed.
Cult director Alejandro Jodorowsky's
planned adaptation of Frank Herbert's novel
Dune
collapsed under the weight of its own ambitions
before it made it off of the drawing board.
But the sketchy outline that survives,
which is lovingly presented in this new documentary,
captures the imagination in ways
that few actual produced sci-fi flicks do.
A South Korean adaptation of a French science
fiction comic
starring Captain America?!
Sold!
Its depiction of a class war aboard a high
tech train
rocketing around a ruined earth
is as thought-provoking as it is thrilling.
This film made a bundle overseas,
but it bombed stateside.
What is WRONG with us, America?!
This satire of romcom cliches starring
Amy Poehler and Paul Rudd
was a hoot.
Some griped that it arrived too late
to really skewer its source material.
Seriously?!
That's like saying that Wet Hot American Summer
is a failure because it was released
two decades after Meatballs!
Hayao Miyazaki is great and all,
but Isao Takahata is the unsung anime genius
of Studio Ghibili.
The director's newest release,
an adaptation of a Japanese folk tale,
came and went from theaters.
But it ranks right up there with his classics
like Pom Poko and Grave of the Fireflies
Let's pour one out for Live Die Repeat,
the Tom Cruise movie formerly known as
Edge of Tomorrow.
Doug Liman's terrific adaptation of the clever
Japanese scifi novel
was the best blockbuster of the year,
and it should've been a HUGE hit.
But it bombed so terribly that the studio
renamed it for the DVD release…
...the way its protagonist continually gets
to relive the last 48 hours
over and over again.
This is a Tom Cruise movie that even Tom Cruise
haters can love!
Thanks to the Groundhog Day-style story structure,
you get to see him die
dozens and dozens of times.
I stand by everything
I said about it at the time of its release--
it's the best movie ever made about video
games,
EVEN THOUGH it's not about video games.
Hmmm, maybe I'll go back in time
and warn the studio not to give it such a
lame title!
AND I'll also warn myself not to eat that
ceviche from 7-11…
[time rewind noise]
By the way, I HATE top 10 lists!
It's such an arbitrary limitation!
I wish it was a top 67 list, so I could've
included:
Cooties, Open Windows, The Rover, Enemy,
The Double, Zero Theorem, Automata, Blue Ruin,
Coherence, Stretch, The Babadook, Under the
Skin,
The Vanquishing of the Witch Baba Yaga--
HEY!
DON'T FADE OUT!
I'M NOT DONE YET!
A Most Wanted Man, To Be Takei,
The Galapagos Affair, Alan Partridge...
What do you think is
the most underrated movie of 2014?
Let me know in the comments
and click down here to subscribe
for more Angry Nerd.
And you can check out more of my reviews
as well as other great clips from Wired
by clicking on any of these...
any of these...
click on any of these...
over here.
On YOUR right.